[Música]
[Aplausos]
repolho
contado
os irmãos calixto
[Música]
ter
e México
em você
[Música]
marca
j
[Música]
que
eu
agora sim não
[Música]
para
seu
[Música]
já perdi
E siga
[Música]
ou
ou não
cheio
ajuda
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para
[Música]
[Aplausos]
um tutorial
este telex
Estou no mês porque estamos indo, mas
novamente
e expressar
e falando sobre cada fase do parque
não existem
perseverou
faça-me lanças porque é um tema de
tempo diferente porque esta quantidade
extensão atual eu tenho uma oferta
de bem-estar e de lugar que é com o
pessoas que eu acredito como coesão
artisticamente profissionalmente no
área muscular profissional
Eu pinto mais e mais pessoas entendem o
fronteiras de restrição cansadas
necessidades e seriedade de nossa nação
porque é dentro de um país
nestas fronteiras territoriais
fronteiras naturais fronteiras
geração de fronteiras pensamentos de
gênero são janelas e abbas nos terminam
eles dizem 'não sobre unidade e sobre entidades
mesmo tempo precioso que é um dos
pequenas desvantagens
ao mesmo tempo que perturbam a identificação
reforçado e criado nas fronteiras das senhoras
de mais barreiras e mais divisões
porque já um pouco de música
[Música]
Oh
eu
meu amor
[Música]
escondendo mais
licença clara
[Música]
a dica de equitação ganha
já
[Música]
e
sim
amar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
aquela parede de festa
sim
[Música]
assim
aquele que gera
visão
[Música]
sim
Nós ganharemos
[Música]
o lugar
sim
[Aplausos]
agora
e mais tarde
ele sabe quem ele é
cristão
[Aplausos]
o sangue
assim
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sim
até que sejam
[Música]
Nós vamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Oh
e
[Música]
Oh
você não faz companhia
em boa companhia também
Espero que você não perca
[Música]
ao meu projeto
leões / foi assim se você quer meu povo
[Música]
cada jantar
mesmo que um beijo
[Música]
palácios
um beijo
[Música]
e para que
saturação
[Música]
a minha
agora
se ganha
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu peguei no começo
opa
cada zona
eu não terminei com isso
[Música]
eu
nada de nada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Oh
dois
ou
[Aplausos]
muitas brigadas e adsense